as of right now
uh give or take the market is pricing in
what will be 10 rate hikes
in uh interest rates and
that we will reach a 300 basis point
interest rate by the end of the year uh
i don't think that you believe that that
is going to happen but you can confirm
that uh i take the under okay the way
under and so what do you think is likely
to happen do we get
five
three where do we end up as an interest
rate at the end of the year
look i
i was
correct
in
march
when i said no way 50
lucky if he does 25.
i was incorrect
in may i said no way 50. no way 75 no
way 75 and no way 50 i thought maybe
another 25. he did 50.
surprisingly um
if you put my feet to the fire pump i'd
say he's done i think the pal pivot is
coming any day now
and uh he just there's just no way
i think he needs a couple
prints on cpi to roll over you know as
oil prices stop going up and his used
car prices start to immediate
uh
ameliorate because that's really 75
percent of the cpi increase
i think if he gets two months of of kind
of flat to down he can back off
i'll i'll say five this year you know
half as many as the market expects and i
think maybe we get to
a buck and a quarter maybe yeah i don't
think there's any maybe get a buck and a
half maybe half and half so five and a
buck and a half so i'm biased in this
last question because uh i think this is
gonna happen
but do you think we get an interest rate
cut before the end of the year
i do i do yeah i i think
i think this fall is going to be
bad i don't think you can go into a
midterm election with uh any level of
inflation uh would be bad but the thing
that's worse than that is a recession
yeah look
you're exactly right i mean we know for
a fact that the number one indicator of
success of the president's party is
gasoline prices number one i mean
inverse relationship low gas prices they
sweep high gas prices they get swept out
and right now at 750 in california
they're out i mean like like
they're all out
if they could they'd get rid of the
president in the midterm at 7.50 i mean
just done
uh
and then the second thing we know
is
that they actually can control
oil prices if they can get saudi to play
ball now
arguably saudi didn't want to play ball
because they won't return his call but
if they could get saudi to pump they
could get oil prices to roll over that
would collapse cpi and that would get
people thinking that we'd be out of the
woods on a recession but remember
recession doesn't mean
back-to-back quarters of negative gdp
okay that's why i think we're in 2001
2001 first quarter was down 1.3 kind of
similar to this year second quarter was
actually positive third quarter
was negative exacerbated by 9 11. i'm
not saying we're gonna have a 9 11. and
then fourth quarter was slightly
positive the year was one percent but
anything sub one and a half is a
recession and so i think we're gonna
have the same kind of mild recession
barring
bad decisions right we put up more
tariffs it gets worse we
do lockdowns
much worse so
there could be some policy errors that
make it worse but i'm with you i i think
uh
we're gonna it's gonna be very clear
that we're in a recession i think we're
already in
and whether it turns from a garden
variety recession
into a depression i'll leave you with
one depressing point
in 1840
the government made a number of policy
decisions that turned a garden variety
recession into a depression in the 1930s
government made two policy decisions
raising rates and smoot hawley that
turned a garden variety recession into
the great depression
now we're 90 years later there's a
90-year cycle go back and read about it
uh
[Music]
jd jd gann
um
and
i
i don't think it necessarily has to
happen
but the picture of the ships
off the ports in china
actually scared me
that was actually a frightening picture
because i know how close we are in
just-in-time inventory and how broken
the system is and then you throw on top
of that you know wheat production
problems and all things you talk about
your your daily newsletter
again don't have to have a depression
but it's not
a zero probability